hi i'm sophie Monk a real life a great
australian celebrity but none of that
matters when i'm doing what i love the
most
travel presenting and what better place
to do it then in town will their last
song you hear chopped off my hand dude
it's already growing back very traumatic
this time we're hearing Hughes bean and
Abbas landing a city notorious for its
criminal activity I'm here with my
friend Pete Pete he is apparently
learning how to steal I have been saving
a lot of stuff I've been stealing from
merchants pickpocketing fencing illicit
goods at the nearest friendly outlaw
refuge sometimes I forget to bribe the
guards and I steal my best stuff that
part sucks such a card
so let me get this straight you just
steal [ __ ] from anyone you come across
no obviously not
since I'll join the Thieves Guild I pick
my missions I collect my riches and then
return when the guild calls for a hero
like me again Oh seriously every time I
come to this place someone trusts people
good me damages it's kind of a done
thing around here take trespassing for
instance don't sneak into homes avoid
detection steal stuff top way to earn
some gold if you good at it I'm not very
good at it well there you have it the
place considered to be the backwater of
hammerfell province has so much to offer
yeah sure it's run by crime bosses but
as usual there's so much to see and do
and so many amazing people to meet
Sippi cool well he gets a bounty on my
head and solitude is quite large how
exciting
I feel so outdoorsy and so adventurous
ah this really is the funnest place ever
so what are you waiting for
ah sick